he Hatriot Mail continues to fly in fast and
furious. Quick reminder, what is hatriot mail?
Take your mask and shove it. Now let me
tell you about my fake medical condition.
Hatriot Mail written by patriots who hate David
Pakman because of America and because freedom.
All right. So I really need your help in
figuring out what on earth this week's Hatriot
is talking about. What what on earth are
they accusing me of? Take a listen to this.
David Pakman is a frustrated loser,
clueless, out of touch, beta, gamma male,
someone who didn't develop socially in a
proper way and who now has a chip on his
shoulder. You're a loser, David, even
though you have a million subscribers.
David Pakman is a very easily triggered beta male
whose personality I can recognize from losers at
school. Growing up, he used the name of a donator
who happened to be a Jew. David Pakman is a loser.
What does this even mean? He he used a name of
a donator who happen to be Jewish. Like is the
allegation that my name isn't really David Pakman,
but I've I've adopted the name David Pakman on the
show because it's the name of a different
Jewish person of I really don't understand
this. And Gammer male. I've never heard like I'm
guessing Gammer male is worse than even beta male.
And of course, that's very inaccurate. I've
always considered myself an epsilon male,
to be totally frank. You can you can check with
people who know me, they will commit to that
epsilon male is much more appropriate.
So listen, the way to fight patriotism
is very simple. Use the coupon code hatriot
forty. When you sign up on my website,
join Pakman dot com. And whenever the code
hatriot forty is used, you save forty percent off
of a membership and the Patriots cry. They're
just bawling their tears. The tears won't stop
flowing and they're maggert tears. To be perfectly
frank, the coupon code is hkt r i o t for zero.